how long were you locked up for three
years uh three and a half the last time
right yeah because you had the YG record
it was u-y-g-i-a-d yeah and then I had
just dropped with Chris Brown right
after that and then you ended up locked
up yeah so it was like a bad it was
terrible because you obviously get close
with Chris Brown from that kidding tour
with fetty WAP right yeah well no I was
cool with Chris
I just was talking about that yeah it
was crazy uh French Montana French was
on it yeah because French was he was
coming out with Chris yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I was actually that tour
might have ended our friendship more
than you and Chris's yeah oh wow
I have no idea